you have a dilemma you ask yourself how
can i play battlefield hardline and you
have spend more money while worry not
wealthy gamer because EA has you covered
with the announcement of battlefield
hardline premium membership will cost
you 50 US dollars or 14 shiny Queen
tokens if you live over here in the UK
and of course it will grant you access
to the usual kind of stuff for these
premium services you'll get exclusive
in-game Musk's each with themes gameplay
benefits you'll also get access to the
gun bench allowing visual customization
of your weapons and be able to track
your kills for each weapon you use there
are also premium only tournaments and
ladders up legendary status of course so
you can replay the progression system
when you max it beyond that premium
members will also get to week advanced
access 24 story themed expansions
criminal activity arriving summer 2015
features highly destructible maps
peppered with small time jobs flummery
also landing this summer is more
head-to-head good times to gain key
locations with major cinematic actions
following that will be getaway in fall
2015 which focuses on high-speed
pursuits from heists and finally there's
betrayal arriving in early 2016 which
will require players to find out who you
trust with a sabotaging rat in the mix
you'll also get 12 gold battlepacks new
personalization options some exclusive
in-game items access to double XP
in-game missions and exclusive events
and finally you'll also get priority
position in server queues are you gonna
be picking up battlefield hardline are
you tempted by any of the premium
offerings let me know in the comment
section below and for the latest on
battlefield make sure you keep your eyes
and ears on gamespot
you